the Joe Rogan experience to me there's
like cleaner meat and there's dirtier
meat III don't really like to eat bears
a lot of people eat bears I've eaten the
one grizzly bear that I ever shot I
didn't shoot him because I wanted to eat
him I shot him because I needed to shoot
him but if I have caribou and moose I
don't really want anything else really
ungulates is what I like to eat right of
course they're cleaner if you see the
stuff that bears eat I don't know why
people are so crazy about bear me some
people really like bear meat but I've
seen what bears eat and I don't really
want to be in bears rotten food oh yeah
I mean you know they just got a lot more
parasites that can actually harm you
yeah like a caribou is a clean animal
there's a couple things they can have
that can hurt you not too bad normally
but a grizzly bear I mean you skin and
um and there's worms this long crawling
out their ass and they got a lot and
those worms can hurt you there yeah you
know they're they're bad if they get
into a person they can cause serious
problems because they don't stay in your
intestines they go into your brain in
different weird places it's the eggs get
into you and they hatch cuz they're an
unfamiliar host they don't know where to
go oh Jesus
you go into spinal cord to go all over
the place what do they do if that
happens to you a lot of kids have have
had big problems get the same kind of
very similar kind of worm lives in
raccoons
so kids play on a playground they you
know raccoon feces has the eggs in it oh
wow it's baylisascaris is the the genus
of worm it's like a round worm normally
it doesn't cause a bear too much problem
it just lives in their intestines but if
that larva if if you get an egg in you
and now the larvae doesn't know where to
go he's an unfamiliar host and they act
differently they'll migrate into weird
places in your body like nervous tissues
getting your eyes and stuff oh Jesus
Christ
yeah yeah oh look at that so there's got
one of their eyes oh Jesus the parasite
on the playground roundworm Wow look at
that man in the eyeball
yeah and what did they do well I never
got one in my eye so I guess [ __ ]
that thing traveling around inside this
person's eyeball doc that man there's a
lot of parasites out there that's the
thing people don't realize it's like
humans used to have a lot of parasites
in them how many people have in their
eyes look at all those pictures of
eyeballs yeah I killed this one bear one
time and those worms they were one on
the left Jamie right the left your
cursor right there click on that that's
15 worms now click on that oh my god
their eyeballs overcome with [ __ ]
worms yeah I've had to deal with those
worms but not in me a 15 centimeter
that's what it says oh that's so long
yeah they're long they're long they're
about as big around as your your pinky
or at least my good this is 14 worms in
this little woman's eye oh my god oh my
god that's so insane oh [ __ ] parasites
man so there's so many parasites it's
creepy like I've seen a lot of parasites
but most unwanted of you moans where
those are one that will and the one
that's in the grizzly bear is just a
slightly different variation from that
one that's in raccoons it's
baylisascaris transfigure lives in the
Grizzlies up there and wearing rubber
gloves when you kind of know and
everything hell no no no but I I did
build a big bonfire right there cuz it
was right in my yard and I just burned
the ground because I got little kids up
there and they were you know crawling
around that time playing and stuff and I
just built this huge bonfire sound and
make sure no eggs the eggs are very
resilient they can last for years and
years in the environment they can
survive being frozen all winter really
oh yeah they're microscopic eggs that's
what you got to worry about not the big
worm you got to worry about the eggs
[ __ ] a lot of bear hunters don't know
this when you're handling a bear skin
those eggs are on the fur yeah if you're
playing around the bear skin before it
gets tan and then you you know you go
like this or something all the sudden
you got those eggs in you scary [ __ ]
[ __ ] that oh oh that's that's one of my
number one fears something creepy crawl
is growing inside me getting in my
eyeballs into my brain tissue I have a
buddy of mine my friend Justin Wren he
does a charity called fight for the
Forgotten
and he builds wells for the pygmies hmm
and we help sponsor him and we do some
things with them and he goes back and
forth to the Congo like a couple times a
year and he went there recently and like
six months ago and has caught a parasite
that they can't identify and they think
it might be in his brain they don't know
where it is but like he'll work out
really hard and then they'll be
shivering with like pale skin and you
know they're trying to do all these
different things to him to try to
eradicate the parasite they don't only
know exactly what he has because he's so
deep into the jungle he's so deep in the
Congo he's going with her a lot of
Western people don't go so they're
they're really baffled don't like we're
known we don't know what the [ __ ] you
have and he's had it for months at
months and months and months of
suffering and just it's taken a toll on
him across the board every every aspect
of his health has deteriorated because
of this it's really creepy I've heard of
people dying from parasites they picked
up in the tropics yeah so when you eat
the wolf what do you eat the backstraps
you do you cook the hams like how do you
how do you eat a wolf the only way that
I like to eat a wolf is a boil it for a
good long time because wolves too will
have parasites they'll have trichinosis
they're meat eaters Nathan eats meat you
wanna make sure it's thoroughly cooked
[Applause]